[Music]
there's some bad news out of afghanistan
i don't know if you guys heard about
this they ran out of lotion it did not
run out of lotion oh okay because it's a
hot place and dry so you don't want to
have no lotion that's probably like one
of my biggest fears you know cracking
knees and stuff and like chapped lips
yeah no it's not because of that okay
good
good
it's actually because all have you guys
seen these pictures of
the taliban fighters who are at the fair
yeah and they brought their guns yeah
and then and then they're riding gold
carts who are the two guys in the middle
because they feel they seem like they're
more uh those two guys holding hands
they're all holding hands how come no
one told them to wear a mask they
weren't they're wearing different
clothes those guys got guns they're more
progressive it's like red white and blue
never mind someone needs to tell them to
put a mask on i think do you guys like
those pictures where they're like on the
swans yeah with their paws
the bumper cars
is that a real video that's a real video
[Laughter]
they have decided to
stop brandishing their weapons on the
fair rides which are still going on by
the way oh that's an american weapon too
by the way because they want to soften
their image they think that they look a
little too hardcore for a lot of people
yeah so they are no longer allowed to
carry their weapons that's my sadness my
favorite [ __ ] is them going to a gym and
[ __ ] around with the workout
equipment did you see it it's the
funniest terrible thing they look like
the gym memes when people don't know
what the machine is like they're just
bouncing like up and down it's like
north when north korea has a bunch of
reporters there and like there's a bunch
of north koreans on the internet and
they don't even know how the [ __ ] to use
it
i'm just like i don't know what do you
what i do just sit here
like this unplugged computer
they're playing it like it's a piano and
[ __ ] did you see that when they're all
dancing to drake no the taliban
yeah they're just all like i don't know
what they're in like it like it looks
like a little club or something they're
feeling it that's when you know you made
it [ __ ] drake course they all still
have their guns out and [ __ ] do you
think drake is smiling about yeah
oh [ __ ] that's the best dude damn
afghanistan's actually beautiful yeah
lovely yeah there's a there's like a
lake with blue water you've been in
vegas to them no that's beautiful dude
it's still funny it's like oh [ __ ]
there's water where's the gas stations
there's a barren desert oh there's water
and it's blue you don't like swimming
dead oh [ __ ] it's reflecting the sky
that's blue dark i know no dude have you
been to see it other lakes like green
and brown pretty gross yeah most lakes
are not beautiful yeah it's beautiful
here they are on the bumper cars
[Music]
i don't know why this is so [ __ ]
funny such a weird [ __ ] mishmash of
worlds so funny dude well i mean this is
what is this specifically the like the
taliban or al-qaeda type stuff or is it
like just afghanistan no no no no no no
no it's the taliban
they've been in the caves so so really
really the news is that they just can't
bring this weapons it's the one that's
the one news is that they're trying to
clean up their
damage because look at how hardcore this
[ __ ] is this is hardcore [ __ ] and people
they're going like people are looking at
us
dude we bring the [ __ ] war i don't
want people looking at them devil got a
rocket launcher dude in the gym that's
the one i was telling you about rocket
launcher that almost has a rocket
launcher in his [ __ ] back you see
that [ __ ] oh the rpg yeah that [ __ ] is
crazy it's crazy that they don't put
them away to do anything they're not
even re-racking their weights
all the time huh just [ __ ] rude i
thought they're not re-racking so like
what did you call me
i have a rocket launcher nothing sorry i
mean i guess it's like back in the day
right where you never leave the sword up
by your side i mean you always have it
with you there's a locker room i know
they look like the painting that's a
gangster-ass picture dude you know
what's crazy with social media and like
god that's all these weapons they stole
from us we left it we left actually like
all right the ones that fell off the
truck the ones we gave them yeah
we left them just because we're such
idiots you know that's all that's the
only reason why okay what's the arms
dude what do you think yeah what do you
think is who may who profited off of
this iran iran yeah [ __ ] yeah i ran well
iran didn't want look up iran's
celebrity net worth
[Laughter]
wait wait so 19 million they're giving
this weapons cash to iran
and then who made the deal you think i
think that you know we want we like to
blame incompetence for things that are
often
worse right so like the idea that
that they just left all these weapons
here and they're like yeah [ __ ] it we
just think it was a coordinated arms
deal with
either our politicians or our like some
kind i think it was absolutely an arms
deal i mean obama and and biden that's
what they did like a couple years ago
they did actual an actual iran nuclear
deal right where they we actually gave
him a pallet of cash and said here you
go wait didn't obama give iran a ton of
cars i don't know yeah there was there
was a
bunch of integris no it was like a ton
of cars like it was an indoor like why
are you doing that right yeah but it's
not new stuff right was he doing that i
forgot the details of it but then the
cia
arms all kinds of countries with weapons
all the [ __ ] time it's the idea that
we just left all these weapons there and
it's just like you always left them
there oh because because our
government's just morons that's why
it's so funny like when i hear like i
hear like republicans talk about this
like brighton's such an idiot can you
believe they lift all those weapons i'm
like yeah that's what happened bro
like there's love they're so stupid
right we just like arming other people
you know this is our thing that's just
our thing historically speaking we love
it i like um watching stuff about arms
dealers because they basically sell to
both sides and then they they don't even
sell the us guns they might even
wholesale buy guns from russia and then
sell it back to russia and their enemies
or some [ __ ] it's [ __ ] weird and they
put stark industries on the side just to
make sure they cover their tracks that
would be really awesome that would be
good right that's crazy man but yeah so
hopefully the towel making soft and
they're pretty hard quarrymen what other
things do they have to do to soften
their image like what other activities
do you want to see the taliban stop
stoning women
and get stoned with women oh that's good
that's the new initiative
holy [ __ ] because afghan kush is some
bomb weed you know what i mean so you
cut to a a taliban guy you pick up a
rock and like no no no no no that's the
psa
and then you're like you should you give
them a j yeah yeah and then they go
oh and then they pass the joint and she
goes
oh yeah and they hold hands and they go
yay seeing a bunch of talibans sitting
around [ __ ] passing the joint for
sure would soften the image big time
there's no way and then they have to
they have to change their whole like
maybe the jihad and the killing idea and
then they like stencil like a peace sign
on all of their [ __ ] is their goal to
just be another like political party in
the future and just not and just put all
this behind like the whole like image of
them i think that's always the goal of
revolutionaries right so like in human
history um
the rebels always become the institution
it all i mean look at the us right like
it's it's built on hey [ __ ] england
we're gonna be our own thing and then
we'll look at what a big empire we are
you know it kind of worked out i think
that their goal is to take away our
freedoms
they ain't gonna do it there's people
that still [ __ ] believe this [ __ ] and
to terrorize us they're like they're
gonna try and terrorize us and [ __ ]
to terrorize they don't like our pork
the american people
and the diplomacy that's why we have to
give them a bunch of porn a bunch of
like vr corn and pork and weed we just
got to drop off a bunch of stuff for
them they're here to take away and fight
against our constitutional rights they
don't like that we have all these
freedoms over here and that's what they
like bumper cars they're okay with me
there's also people who believe
that america has a moral right to have
to go into all these countries and
[ __ ] clean them up from their
dictators that we actually prop up the
neocons because we do have them all
right do you think it's all neocons
because i feel like the democrats also
believe that democrats are neocons too
they're just neolibs now yeah that's
true same [ __ ] same corporation yeah
yeah establishment candidates
neoconservative yeah so that was a term
coined during i think the bush era yeah
the bush
bush bush cheney were neocons and don
russell's neocon yeah yeah because that
was a different republican camp versus
the trump camp right when he said neocon
i was imagining the font
you know who i've been watching recently
tool i think is [ __ ] crushing it is
russell brand
i really like what he's doing because um
like his whole channel is about
kind of being in the middle because he
doesn't want to affiliate himself with a
political party but try to get the
public to just like watch all this
[ __ ] that's going on which is
mainstream media colluding with the
military industrial complex and right
now he's like why is the mainstream
media attacking joe rogan so hard right
and he's like i'm usually skeptical when
they sensationalize and divert something
when there's some major thing going on
which is ukraine so right now with
ukraine
we might even break into war with russia
like they're not even talking about this
[ __ ] on the scale that we should be the
state department just said yesterday
that they're expecting russia to do a
false flag attack to justify an invasion
of ukraine and that just means that
that's what the cia wants us all to
think oh wait right now they actually
reported that russia is making false
flag videos of that so they're loading
up their troops to get ready to invade
to justify the invasion and then what is
america gonna probably say is like we
gotta go and help our allies that's
right and we have to go in but it's
again it's another war
for
presidents in power to profit because
bush did it with iraq and afghanistan
right now biden we all know that hunter
biden has um interests in ukraine it's
been said during the campaign it it's
been confirmed that he has um like
business interests that confirmed it
after the election the day yeah i
thought it was before it was during the
day they were talking about during the
election but then all these places would
memory hold it and say that you can't
talk about that right now but then he
has if he has assets in ukraine he's
gonna try to prep he's just gonna try to
[ __ ] protect his assets by going in
right and not let russia take and
[ __ ] do whatever's with it yeah
because they use these countries to to
pump a bunch of money through it filter
a bunch of money through it they hire
their guys they get their guys in like
paul bremer in iraq they were filtering
so much [ __ ] money through iraq all
this dirty money that gets turned into
clean money and they go exported
elsewhere and and take it back home and
all kinds of [ __ ] it's [ __ ] nuts it's
the best
it's just war on terror in neo geo
[Music]
you